i was wondering this yesterday i was
like
like i see people on twitter or reddit
they
talk about like oh man like i like it
when they talk about anime i don't like
it when they talk about anime i guess
it's weird because i guess when we
started it was like
i guess we said we were the anime
podcast well our channel
bio i think is a terrible animation yeah
yeah if you don't want our about section
that's what it says i always never give
a [ __ ] that much about anime
um wow just come out and see it no
i i always had a genuine question for
you which is do you see yourself as an
anime youtuber
i i the thing is i think because i see
myself in the same like realm
yeah with like those people cause you
hang out with us right i'm hanging out
with you guys i watch a lot of anime i
make
i think because i make so many anime
references and it's so much like anime
and yeah otaku culture in my videos i
guess i do
but not in the traditional sense like
because i don't make videos about anime
but yeah but that's the thing right it's
like nowadays you make any content
that's like
even if you make content that's just
like general otaku [ __ ] like yuu or aki
yeah
just because like i think otaku just
equals anime now well i think the type
of people who watch my stuff are people
who consume anime right
right right but i'm not necessarily
talking about anime i don't know it's
it's weird right because i've i've been
like as the og anime youtuber it's so
weird seeing anime content on youtube
nowadays
and this is just me thinking out loud
but do people even want to see
as much like anime content as much
anymore and
because i feel like it's been really
weird seeing
content on anime content on youtube in
2020 where
it feels like anime content doesn't even
perform
that amazingly anymore compared to doing
like
compared to doing like anime themed
content as opposed to
i am going to make content on a certain
show it's it's otaku content now yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i mean when we started the podcast
i was kind of worried i was like [ __ ]
they're gonna want to talk about anime
every week
because i can't talk i mean i mean is
that is
technically speaking that is what we
sought out to do exactly when we were
discussing it
i remember in my head i'm like i'm just
gonna like bring up other stuff
we'll just see how it does right like
well it's so i could have backfired so
much
it's funny because the only the time i
talked about anime most
is on the podcast with you guys right
really do we actually talk about anime
off-screen yeah yeah yeah
i feel like there's more people like i
guess if you want to get into it like
more people way qualified than us to
talk about it
yeah like just consuming anime all they
do is talk about anime
yeah but i also in my opinion like
when i do want to consume stuff about
anime i often don't want that kind of
person who's just like
all they do is anime i kind of want just
like a monkey brain person kind of
like yeah this is why like
i think the only anime reviews i still
watch which is [ __ ] weird to say is
like i watch critical
yeah reviews because i know that when
i'm getting that i'm getting a review
from something that's oh that's also
like someone like critical can pretty
much just
do content on anything but i think
because i've
been on youtube for so long and i've
been throughout all of my anime watching
lifespan if you will yeah whenever i
wanted to see if i wanted to watch a
show i would just go and watch
a review from someone who all they do is
talk about anime all they do is consume
anime
and culture yeah and it's just really
refreshing to now go and watch someone
who doesn't really care that much about
anime but they do like it a lot like
it's not their entire life right like
it's just like
i'm a normal guy i do things but i also
watch a lot of adam
yeah i i feel like that attitude really
reflects on
how you know how anime content performs
on youtube as well it's because
i i feel like if you only do anime
content and you like you like only
i feel like because anime has gotten so
much more mainstream in the past few
years
it's it's not so much about being an
anime fan
you know what i mean like there are
definitely channels that's you know
i'm probably like one of the biggest
where you focus solely on anime but i
feel like
they're you you hit a ceiling right you
you hit the ceiling of
okay if you only if you only target
yourself towards anime fans
that community now is so only so big
but anime as a medium is actually bigger
like the anime community because like
you can be you can be like a
true like anime fan follow seasonal
anime and everything like that
but then there's like a way bigger
community that knows about anime
and you know watches the odd anime show
but they
also don't have as much of a vested
interest are you talking about
normies maybe i am talking about it
like they don't have a vested interest
or they're not as invested i basically
sum it up i like watching normal reviews
it's it's a different show
it's the difference between anime fans
and people who are
fans of anime i feel there's like a big
difference right because like an
anime fan is like someone where it's
like anime is their life like
they love everything about it they'll
watch anything they'll you know
dedicate their life to it and then there
are fans of anime where it's like
i i got the perfect word there are anime
fans yeah and then there are weebs
yeah yeah
just disregard everything i just said no
because someone is like
because like as you were saying i also
want to say that like we
we like we we're weebs
that's why because like i i was thinking
to myself like what differentiates
someone
someone like critical from someone like
in the anime community because i'm i
it made me think remember the good old
days of gatekeeping
and b you mean 20 20. yeah
and like the the old days where like
you're not a true
anime fan unless you've watched xxx show
yeah like
oh you're an anime fan name me 20
different shows that aren't your
return to me or my anime exactly right
name every anime
stuff yeah i've done that well like i'm
like it's it's good
that nowadays i feel like gatekeeping
especially in the anime community it's
like it's not dyed but it's definitely
way less than it used to be but i feel
like someone like critical i feel like
he has watched a lot of anime right
and he does definitely i think he
actually watches more anime than me yeah
i i
i think he does as well but i don't know
like you look at critical and you're
like you're not a weep you know what i
mean you're just you're just
just a normal anime fan you know felix
was like that too like at one point he
was doing a bunch of like anime reviews
and he was doing a lot of videos on
anime and i'm just like okay i i can
tell like
you like anime but obviously your entire
life is not anime
right and i think that's why people
really liked his reviews right yeah it
felt like a very honest it's not a new
it was like a new it was a it was a new
perspective of
opinions on certain shows because i feel
like when maybe you're an anime youtuber
uh when you're reviewing an anime it's
like i'm reviewing it because it's an
anime
whereas i feel like like if a critical
or pewdiepie or any
any other person makes a review who
doesn't talk about anime content yeah it
feels like they have something to say
because they've gone out of their way to
make a video about something they
normally wouldn't make a video about
right to talk about it whereas you know
gone talking about attack on titan
season four
of course god's going to talk about
attack on titans you know what i mean
like it's expected and it's because he
wants those views right
but yeah but obviously i mean but if
someone else does it right it's like oh
they must really like be passionate
about what they're trying to
convey here and i think that's something
that's really refreshing and that's
something that
maybe this is again this could be from
being a youtuber myself right and i can
understand the thought process of why
they're talking about it
yeah but i don't know i i guess and
that's why
i think i've distanced myself from anime
in some aspects
and it's like and it's like not to
undermine the passion of actual anime
fans right like you know
i'm sure there's uh i still [ __ ] love
this yeah i'm sure
i'm sure there's a massive amount of
like hardcore anime fans who will make
attack on titan videos because they're
shaking of course of course yeah sorry
but yeah i'm not trying to say that yeah
no no
yeah but like no no i i get what you're
saying it's like
when you do see that anime review from
someone who
yeah you do don't you expect an anime
review yeah it's just like oh
okay because like look looking on the
internet now there's like
so many so many low-key anime fans that
you know that's
they're just like like suddenly coming
out of the woodwork it's like
it's like yeah i've always been an anime
yeah it's it's it's like sometimes you
see these little hints every now and
then
now and again where it's like this
completely normal youtuber that you
don't expect to watch anime and then
like make a very subtle anime reference
and
you're just like wait are you a weeb did
you have something to say
that's why i always get like scared and
surprised when
a youtuber who i thought had nothing to
do with anime like follows me on twitter
i'm like
something's up something's up do you
perhaps like anime
or maybe they've just seen like wow this
guy likes a lot of porn that i like yeah
i should follow him back because i
remember i was watching like
one of the latest internet historian
videos like a few weeks ago
and then like you know it was it was a
very normal internet historian vid uh
video then right at the end he was like
giving some shout outs to like his other
social medias
and then he mentioned like streaming and
everything and then he showed a clip of
carone and i'm just like
where where where did this come from
yeah yeah he did
yeah it's like right it's like right at
the end as well so
it's it's at the point where most people
click off good taste good yes
i'm like are you a cultured individual
too would you like to come up to the
podcast
and talk about the goddess that is